[Applause]
all right welcome back safety blitz
starting two-time super bowl champ
rodney harrison jack collins or
something we call third and short here i
want to run you through them i want to
start in new york new york is one of
those teams potentially in the russell
wilson
stakes after this year we'll see where
russ ends up maybe he goes back seattle
who knows but what would you do joe
judge and their quarterback daniel jones
either one of them would you keep what
would you do with that situation overall
um i would move i would move on from
daniel jones i just don't think i don't
think he's special i think he's a
average quarterback and if they want to
continue to get average results or below
average results you'll keep him and then
we'll see what happens with joe judge
next year but daniel jones i mean he's a
good athlete at times he looks good but
just the decision making the level of
inconsistent play there's no way that i
feel like they can really trust him to
get over that hump
and rod nobody knows new england and
what's going on there with new england i
want to ask you about joe judge real
quick i probably would do the same i may
give jones one more year to try to show
something but
i'm a little cooled off on him a little
bit joe judge in new england though the
fact that they even brought him in and
hired him like what did you know about
him during his time in new england that
might get him ahead what did you what
did you heard about joe judge
forgive me for this be because i don't
even i don't even think he was there
when i was there i was there for six
years so i don't even i didn't even know
the guy like when i started broadcasting
they started mentioning this guy joe
judge and i started paying attention to
them but i don't know him i've never i
don't remember meeting them anything
like that so i don't i have no
connection to them
but there's a whole bunch of people in
new england you talk to it's like that's
who they're gonna hire you know if you
could have anybody from the staff that
joe judge would be the first name that
they go to it was kind of dumbfounding
but i guess the results have followed
along with that we'll get you to the
second one on third and short which is
russell wilson if he is not in a
seahawks uniform what would be the right
fit in your mind's eye for russ
oh that's easy that's easy oh that's so
so easy
new orleans would be a perfect place for
us playing indoors
man in new orleans man they would
absolutely love him they're going to
continue to add talent he's got an
unbelievable defense he's going to have
he's got a good offensive line you got
alvin kamara man no question about it
new orleans would be a perfect place for
russell wilson they would embrace him
and he doesn't have to do everything by
himself like i said that defense is
outstanding they're going to continue to
add to that a what better place than
than new orleans what do you think
so i almost have to take this one from
the perspective of sierra
it's almost what i have to do it's going
to be a family decision it's gonna be a
family decision and i think gisele
wanted to be in florida
okay tom brady's in florida i think
sierra might want to be in new york and
would that be enough to make him a giant
i don't know it's hard it's hard for me
to see
him not being at least interested that
family being interested being in new
york maybe san francisco would they want
to be in northern california that seems
like a pretty good place to live there's
good money to be invested in tech and
all of those things out there could that
be a possibility for him vegas a little
residency out there for sierra right we
get a little residency good money no
travel sierra wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i don't wait wait i don't know
wait now you now you now you're being
disrespectful to derek carr
i mean this guy's played well like we've
criticized him and things like that but
at the end of the day the guy has played
well so now you're saying that if you're
the raiders you'll get rid of derek carr
for russell wilson
i mean i don't want to disrespect
derrick carr cause i do like him but if
you're telling me i could have russell
wilson i would make that trade
absolutely absolutely i would make that
trade wow
wow and you know what what do you think
i could say about dare cart just
of course
absolutely it's it's an upgrade
yeah it is i mean it is i mean it is
russell wilson's a hall of famer you
know so that's not even fair like derek
carr is doing his thing and he's had
some you know he had some last few years
he's been good or whatever but at the
end of the day he's not russell wilson
this is a guy that has experience he won
a super bowl and he knows how to lead
and he just doesn't seem happy in
seattle like once you i've been one of
those free agents why i left one place
and went and got embraced and fell back
in love with football and i think that's
what russell wilson needs he needs a
change of scenery he needs to go
somewhere where they can show him new
love hey russ we appreciate you you know
he doesn't know really a lot of people
just a new fresh start but i but you
know what what you said about new york
is true because he does have to consider
what his wife where she wants to be in
new york compared to new orleans as far
as her entertainment
i get it
hey these become group decisions baby we
know that okay let's get you to the
third one here on third and short which
is aaron rodgers this could be back to
back mvp seasons for aaron rodgers where
should he be in 2022
he sure oh that's easy he should
definitely stay with the green bay
packers like matt leflore who knows and
understands aaron rodgers more i mean
who knows how to deal with his ups and
downs his attitudes his weird little
things that happens it's matt leflore
and he's a big reason why aaron rodgers
has back to back well he's going to have
back-to-back mvps and he should stay
there their offensive line will continue
to get healthier he's got he'll have one
of the best offensive lines in all of
football he's got two really good backs
he's got the best wide receiver in all
of football and he's got to improve in
defense where would you want to go and
plus you get a chance to play in lambeau
field in front of 60 000 crazy fans that
don't care about
10 10 degree weather like why would you
want to leave like i was there we were
there twice this year and
i'm like this is really a sacred place
like it it is really once you get a
chance to be there and really absorb and
meet the fans and the history it is
really really a special place aaron
rodgers please don't leave green bay i
don't want to see another uniform
i i i kind of i kind of think that
you're right man if you had asked me
like five weeks ago i think i would have
thought he was gone somewhere warm
that's just what i was thinking he's
ready to get somewhere warm but why
would he like nobody plays better cold
weather football there roger that's an
advantage nobody so why do you want to
give that advantage back you know like
he seems to just love it and thrive uh
with that and now that he has a
relationship i just think he needed to
feel a little bit of the love man he
needed to feel a little bit out of he
saw tom brady down there recruiting guys
building his team playing a little bit
of gm while he also plays quarterback
and he wanted to be involved in those
conversations but i think he voiced
those opinions you know he said i want
to be involved and i think they listened
and now he's been more involved and
you're seeing him smile more that's how
i see it
that point that point that you just made
is huge the fact that they allow him to
have input on some of the decisions
that's made offensively
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports